and i read a book too i'm reading it
actually it's not fully read
but this book is partially read by me so
far
in a book by mike lindell you heard of
this fellow riley mal
i have not you read a lot sometimes it
depends
depends what i read sound like you don't
read that much but i'll tell you right
now about this book
this book by mike lindell is my pillow
you ever heard of my pillows
the the tv commercial my pillows yeah
yeah
so the man was doing crack the man was a
crack addict
for at least 190 pages of the book he's
smoking crack you can almost smell the
crack
it would almost be cool if they had put
a scratch and sniff on the page we could
smell a crack a little
because i've never smoked crack to be
honest with you but i always wish that i
had
um but anyway
throughout the book he's smoking crack
and he's doing this and that and he's
struggling and
um man it's a fascinating story the
story is fascinating i mean people i
know sometimes
on twitter give the guy a hard time you
know he's a pretty devout republican
and he's um uh
well i don't know what else he is i mean
he i think he's a
vikings fan but
the man was smoking crack and then made
one of the most successful pillows of
all time
you know name another can you name
another pillar riley
um yeah the uh
what do you call it um
you can't think of it because you can't
think of it dude and that's why
the uh therapy therapeutic um no
no nope that's a mattress you're you're
talking tempo
yeah you're right yep pillow is just for
your head mattress is for your body
right and so what i'm telling you about
is this man was smoking crack and then
he made
one of the most successful pillows of
all time
and that doesn't happen on accident
that doesn't happen on accident if
you're smoking crack for
20 30 40 years
the odds of you making one of the most
successful
pillows of all time
is very small
and so what i'm saying is man and i
appreciate the call
and what i'm saying is just like yeah
it's hard to you know sometimes you got
to take that chance
but not only that you got to put your
best foot forward
and so i feel like we're trying
something new out here um
but at the same time we were also trying
to put our best foot forward
but thank you for that call man for the
good for the good fortune good evening
good afternoon
and other times thanks for watching that
video you just saw
i mean it was okay but the next video
you can watch
could be way better what if you watch a
video right now that changes your life
well you could watch this one or watch
this one watch this one watch this one
watch this one